ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen 19
Kinder und mindestens zwei Erwachsene
sind gestorben in juveldi einer
Kleinstadt in Texas ermordet von einem
Amokläufer 19 Kinderbetten die heute
Nacht leer sein werden Väter Mütter
Geschwister fassungslos auf Twitter
versuchen sie ihre Trauer zum Ausdruck
zu bringen
ich liebe dich für immer und immer
kleine Schwester mögen deine Flügel
höher steigen als du jemals träumen
konntest
Lexi war so ein helles Licht im Leben du
hast diese Welt viel zu früh verlassen
und wirst für immer vermisst werden
alles worum ich bitte ist dass ihr eure
Lieben heute umarmt und ihnen sagt dass
ihr sie liebt man weiß nie wann man dazu
keine Chance mehr haben wird
es tut mir so leid dass ich vergessen
habe heute guten Morgen zu sagen ich
liebe dich für immer kleine Schwester
tja unfassbare Trauer bei den
Angehörigen und bei einem ganzen Land
die Frage warum diese Frage stellt sich
wieder einmal und sie stellt sich auch
in der Hinsicht dahin wie man so etwas
verhindern kann dass es wieder passiert
und eine andere Frage stellt der
amerikanische Präsident selbst wann in
Gottes Namen werden wir der Waffenlobby
die Stirn bieten fragt Joe Biden es sei
höchste Zeit Schmerz in Taten zu
verwandeln darüber sprechen wir in
diesem Stream sehr gerne auch mit Ihnen
wie immer ihre und eure Kommentare in
die Kommentare oder wenn ihr die App
nutzt an ZDF heute - live at zdf.de
unser Korrespondent in den USA ist Elmar
thewesen zugeschaltet aus Washington
Elmar wie ist die Situation im Moment
wie werden die Angehörigen vor Ort
betreiben
ja die Angehörigen werden in einem
Gemeinschaftszentrum betreut das in
diesem kleinen Ort der hat etwa 15.000
Einwohner halt existiert wo man sonst
zusammen auch feiert miteinander aber in
diesem Fall eben jetzt die Angehörigen
betreut werden viele sind seit gestern
Abend da manche wussten über Stunden
nicht ob ihre Kinder tatsächlich lebend
davon gekommen sind es gab
Schwierigkeiten diese Informationen
möglichst schnell auch an die Eltern
weiterzugeben für viele ist dann eben am
Abend schreckliche Gewissheit entstanden
dass ihre Kinder unter den Opfern sind
es sind Psychologen natürlich vor Ort es
sind aber gleichzeitig eben auch
Sicherheitskräfte vor Ort die den Tatort
weiträumig abgesperrt haben die jetzt
die forensischen Untersuchungen
vornehmen genau überprüfen was ist da
vor Ort genau geschehen aber natürlich
auch den Hintergrund des Täters der
18-Jährige ist ja von Polizisten dann
erschossen worden und man versucht jetzt
etwas mehr über seine Motive natürlich
herauszubekommen ein bisschen was davon
hören wir schon dass er zumindest in den
vergangenen Jahren schon aufgefallen ist
nicht nur durch gewalttätige Ausdrücke
in seiner Sprache sondern er neigt auch
zu Selbstverletzungen er hat immer
wieder Drohungen
ausgestoßen und er war ganz offenbar in
der Lage bei seinem 18 Geburtstag vor
wenigen Tagen zwei halbautomatische
Waffen Gewehre zu kaufen hier dann bei
dieser schrecklichen Tat auch genutzt
hat ja und genau das ist einer der
Punkte den wir vertiefen wollen in
diesem Stream das Thema Waffen und
Waffen Lobby in den USA ich guck mal
kurz in den Chat ich sehe hier sehr viel
Mitgefühl und viele Userinnen und User
die selbst auch sehr betroffen sind Kerl
alban schreibt zum Beispiel über Youtube
bis wann dürfen solche schockierenden
Vorfälle passieren wir versuchen das ein
bisschen auf zu analysieren gleich im
Stream schauen aber erstmal noch mal
genau was passiert ist du hast einen
Beitrag darüber gemacht
sie haben das wertvollste verloren was
es gibt ihre Kinder unter Ihnen haben
wir Lopes 10 Jahre voller Lebensfreude
sagt seine Familie es ist gerade Mittag
als der Schütze Leben und Hoffnungen
zerstört mit halbautomatischen Waffen
bringt er in die Grundschule einer
ermordet 19 Mädchen und Jungen und zwei
Erwachsene trifft die Menschen im
kleinen Ort in ihre Herzen juvalde hat
15.000 Einwohner
Polizisten konnten in 18-Jährigen
Salvador Air nach einem Feuergefecht
erschießen er stand aus einer
zerrütteten Familie wurde häufig gemobbt
gerade erst konnte er an seinem
Geburtstag problemlos die Waffen kaufen
US-Präsident beiden sichtlich
erschüttert entschlossen einmal mehr
eine Verschärfung der Waffengesetze
anzugehen
Gottes Willen stehen wir endlich auf
gegen die Waffenlobby
die Flaggen auf halbmaß aber
Republikaner im Kongress verweigern ihre
Unterstützung
schon seht ihr Demokraten und viele in
den Medien die das verfassungsmäßige
Recht gesetzestreuer Bürger einschränken
wollen
meine Kollegen warum machen Sie sich die
Mühe in den us-szenar zu kommen wenn
ihre einzige Antwort auf das
Massensterben auf Kinder die um ihr
Leben rennen wenn ihre einzige Antwort
ist dass wir nichts tun
Amerie Eva Usia Annabel und viele mehr
Amerika ist das einzige Land der Erde
das es Mördern so einfach macht Leben
und Hoffnungen zu zerstören
dann lass uns das Vertiefen Elmar ein
User namens immer mit der Ruhe fasst es
ganz gut zusammen er sagt es ist nicht
nur das Lasche Waffengesetz sondern die
Kombination aus der Gesetzeslage und dem
gesellschaftsklima das in den USA
herrscht würdest du dem zustimmen und
wie geht dieses Amerika nun an diesem
Tag direkt wenige Stunden nach der Tat
damit um
ja ich glaube das stimmt schon wenn wir
uns anschauen dass wir einerseits sehr
Lasche Waffengesetze hier in den USA
haben und wir können gleich auch noch
gerne in Details einsteigen wie das
genau aussieht kommt eben dazu dass es
eine Haltung in den USA gibt die von
Angst geprägt ist die dafür gesorgt hat
dass die Waffenverkäufe in den letzten
Jahren in die Höhe geschnellt sind will
aber ein Beispiel nennen im Jahr 2020
hat es Waffenverkäufe gegeben von 40
Millionen Waffen in den USA und das ist
ein Anstieg zu den Vorjahren ein
massiver Anstieg hat möglicherweise eben
auch mit der sehr ich sag mal
turbulenten politischen aber auch
sozialen Situationen in den USA mit der
Polarisierung im Land mit den Unruhen
die es im Land gegeben hat aber auch
natürlich mit der corona-pandemie und
dem psychischen Folgen für viele zu tun
das hat ein Klima der Angst sicherlich
noch mal ein Stück weit ausgedehnt und
deswegen sind so viele Waffen so einfach
verfügbar in diesem Land
und dann kommt das eine zum anderen ein
Täter der ganz offenbar
Schwierigkeiten hatte in seinem Leben in
seiner Familie aber er hätte solch eine
Tat wie gestern nie begehen können wenn
er nicht so einfach eben an diese Waffen
herangekommen wäre jetzt ist es ja nicht
das erste Mal dass sowas passiert und
auch nicht das erste Mal dass diese
Diskussion geführt wird auf Twitter wir
können vielleicht gerade mal hier auf
den Laptop schalten auf das Notebook da
sieht man ganz gut da hat jemand
zusammengefasst was was immer passiert
wenn sowas passiert also es gibt eine
einen einen
massenschießerei oder ein Amoklauf wie
in diesem Fall dann gibt es eine große
mediale Aufgeregtheit dann gibt es
Betroffenheit und Gebete für die Opfer
dann gibt es auf Social Media Debatten
über Waffengewalt dann macht niemand
irgendwas und am Ende kehren alle wieder
zur Normalität zurück glaubst du dass es
dieses Mal anders sein wird
ehrlicherweise nein und wenn ihr mir ein
bisschen Zeit gebt will ich einmal kurz
durchgehen durch das was in den letzten
20 30 Jahren in den USA passiert ist es
gab schon einmal eine Zeit als
halbautomatische Waffen hier in den USA
verboten waren das war 1994 bis 2010
damals fand man offenbar die politische
Kraft über die Lager hinweg eben dieses
Gesetz zu verabschieden zehn Jahre war
es in Kraft aber dann lief es
automatisch aus und es gab niemanden der
bereit war die Mehrheiten dafür zusammen
zu bekommen um es zu verlängern wir
erinnern uns vielleicht auch vor knapp
zehn Jahren gab es dann das Massaker an
der Sandy Hook Grundschule in Newton in
Connecticut damals sind 26 Menschen
gestorben allein 20 kleine Kinder an
dieser Grundschule und danach gab es
eben auch all diese Versprechungen man
hat sich auch aufgemacht übergreifend
über die Parteien im Kongress hier
Republikaner und
Demokraten ein neues dies zu entwerfen
um zumindest ein Stück weit die
Waffengesetze zu verschärfen hier in den
USA dieses Gesetz ist weniger Monate
später im April 2013 ganz krachen
gescheitert es gab keine Mehrheit dafür
ganz offenbar dann 2016 kam Donald Trump
ans Ruder hier in den USA 2018 in
Florida an der parkland High School ein
Massaker bei dem damals 17 Schüler und
Lehrer getötet worden sind kurz danach
hat Donald Trump versprochen dagegen
muss man was tun er hat Initiativen
gestartet er hat sich vor die Kameras
gestellt und erklang eigentlich sehr
überzeugend zu diesem Zeitpunkt aber er
hat sich dann eben mit der Waffenlobby
getroffen und kurz danach war diese
Initiative wieder in sich
zusammengefallen und es gab dann später
eben noch mal im Jahr
2020 2019 Entschuldigung ja die Schuld
die Schießereien hier in den USA in
Texas und in Ohio wenn ich mich
vorstellen Sinne kurz danach hat man
noch mal einen Versuch gestartet da gab
es auch bei den Republikanern
Bereitschaft mitzumachen aber das was da
angefangen wurde zumindestens mal über
eine Verschärfung zu beraten und die
amerikanische Regierung unter Donald
Trump war mit dem Boot der
Justizminister Bar damals das ist alles
im Sande verlaufen aus einem ganz
einfachen Grund es wurde bekannt dass
Donald Trump damals Druck auf den
Präsidenten der Ukraine selenski
ausgeübt hatte daraus würde eine
Amtsenthebungsverfahren und da war jede
Möglichkeit sich zu einigen über die
Parteigrenzen hinweg war fortan also
über mehr als zehn Jahre mittlerweile
keine Verschärfung der Waffengesetze und
wenn man noch mal Sandy Hook nimmt
damals 2012 seitdem gab es in den USA
3.500 Massaker das sind im Urlaub
Schießereien wo mehr als vier Menschen
getötet werden
3.500 mastercar in zehn Jahren aber eben
keine Veränderung der Waffengesetzen
Waffen Beschränkungen schärfere Gesetze
würden helfen dass es hier von vielen
die Meinung im Chat albern B schreibt
über YouTube nicht nur
waffenbeschränkungen würden helfen
sondern auch ein besseres und
menschlicheres gesundheitsschul und
sozialarbeitersystemen ist ein ganz
wichtiger Punkt und Nicole Baumann
schreibt auf Facebook man muss es den
Menschen nicht noch extra einfach machen
die Laschen Waffengesetze sorgen unter
anderem dafür dass schon Kinder wissen
wie man damit umgeht und da gibt es dann
keinerlei Hemmungen mehr und wir schauen
uns an einer der sich heute in Amerika
selbst sehr aufgeregt hat über die
Waffengesetze die unbedingt verschärft
werden müssen ist Steve curr ein
prominenter NBA Basketballtrainer der
Golden State Warriors und der hat heute
in seiner Pressekonferenz nicht über
Sport gesprochen sondern er hat einfach
die Schnauze richtig voll
nun also auch Kinder ermordet in der
Schule wann wollen wir endlich etwas
dagegen tun
ich finde es leid so leid immer wieder
mein Beileid auszusprechen an die am
Boden zerstörten Familien genug der
Entschuldigungen genug des stillen
Gedenkens
ich habe satt
wir werden heute Abend hier spielen aber
jeder hier sollte jetzt an sein eigenes
Kind Enkel Mutter Vater Schwester Bruder
denken wie würden Sie sich fühlen wenn
sie direkt betroffen wären
dabei sind 90 Prozent aller Bürger dafür
für eine Überprüfung von waffenkäufen
90% und nur 50 Senatoren in Washington
sind gegen eine Abstimmung sind gegen
den erklärten Willen der Mehrheit
diese 50 nehmen uns in Geiselhaft sie
wollen nicht abstimmen sondern nur an
der Macht bleiben erbärmlich so etwas
sehr emotionale Statement das heute
wirklich viral gegangen ist im Netz
immer er spricht an die sogenannte hr8
das ist eine Gesetzesvorlage die seit
2019 quasi festhängt eine
Gesetzesvorlage die genauere background
checks bei Waffenlieferungen vorsieht
aber im Senat blockiert wird kannst du
das genauer erklären
ja tatsächlich hat man 2019 nach den
mastercon von denen ich vorhin sprach
versucht eben ein neues Gesetz im
Abgeordnetenhaus durchzubringen und das
hat auch geklappt warum weil die
Demokraten seit dem Jahr 2018 im
Repräsentantenhaus eine Mehrheit hatten
und zwar eine deutlich große Mehrheit so
dass sie dieses Gesetz verabschieden
konnten es ist dann an den Senat
gegangen und dort liegen geblieben
sicherlich auch wegen des vorhin
beschriebenen dass eben die Mehrheit
nicht zu finden war weil man sich
politisch so sehr zerstritten hatte über
das Amtsenthebungsverfahren von Donald
Trump das Repräsentantenhaus hat dann in
der Amtszeit von Joe Biden jetzt noch
einmal dieses Gesetz verabschiedet und
wieder weitergeleitet an den Senat aber
im Senat gibt es eben diese knappe
Mehrheit für die Demokraten die sind
darauf angewiesen dass wenn es 5050 ist
dass dann eben Kamila Harris die
Vizepräsidentin die entscheidende Stimme
abgibt und insgesamt reicht das eben
nicht weil wenn man ein
das Gesetz das ja die amerikanische
Verfassung auf betrifft dort ist das
Waffenrecht jedenfalls nach Auffassung
vieler verankert wenn man so ein Gesetz
verändern will dann braucht man
eigentlich eine klare Mehrheit im Senat
die Republikaner können in dieser Lage
momentan auch verhindern dass es zur
Abstimmung kommt durch den sogenannten
Filibuster man bräuchte also zehn
republikanische Senatoren die mit den
Demokraten gemeinsam gegen den
Filibuster in diesem Fall und dann eben
auch für die Verabschiedung dieses
Gesetzes stimmen das ist völlig
illusorisch diese Mehrheit gibt es nicht
die Demokraten hoffen natürlich dass sie
durch Wahlen in Zukunft dann eine
größere Mehrheit bekommen aber ganz
ehrlich gesagt alle umfragen sagen dass
bei den Kongresswahlen im Herbst ist
eher sehr sehr knapp wird für die
Demokraten überhaupt diese knappen
Mehrheiten zu behalten geschweige denn
auszubauen also ich glaube eine
Verschärfung des Waffenrechts ist in den
USA in den nächsten Jahren nicht
wirklich in Sicht dazu gibt es eine
Frage von Gabriel an dich ist zu
befürchten dass die Republikaner den
Amoklauf für die mit terms gegen beiden
nutzen werden
ja ehrlicherweise ist das schon im Gange
das eine ist das was Anführer der
republikanischen Partei öffentlich sagen
und da ist beispielsweise Senator Ted
Cruise aus Texas der sehr klar gemacht
hat kaum passiert sowas schon springen
die Demokraten wieder vor die Kameras
schon ereifert man sich in den Medien
und will den gesetzestreuen Bürgern das
Waffenrecht das ihnen verfassungsmäßig
garantiert ist einschränken also eine
klare Ansage von der Führung der
republikanischen Partei dass man davon
gar nicht hält und hinter den Kulissen
sehen wir in rechten Foren
rechtskonservativen Foren in den USA
schon Beschimpfungen und wie man sich ja
eifert über den Täter es wird in
simuiert weil er einen hispanischen
Hintergrund hat dass der ja irgendwann
mal oder seine Familie über die Grenze
aus Mexiko gekommen sei und das deshalb
die offene Grenze schuld sei an dem Tod
dieser Schüler das gebe ich nur deshalb
wieder weil das ein relevanter Faktor
ist tatsächlich es gibt innerhalb dieser
konservativen ich sag mal teilweise
rechtsextremen Bewegung in den USA
besonders getrieben vom trampismus gibt
es eine sehr nennenswerte Zahl von
Wählern die diese Überzeugungen hegen
und das könnte eben bei den
Kongresswahlen auch genutzt werden um
weiter Stimmung zu machen und weiter
Anhänger für die Trump Pisten hier in
den USA zu gewinnen wobei man ja auch
dazu sagen muss dass die Opfer auch
diesen Hintergrund haben und man aus
genau demselben Grund argumentieren
könnte oder sich fragen könnte ob es
vielleicht ein rassistischer Anschlag
gewesen ist
absolut also wir müssen klar sagen
dieser 18-Jährige hat eine spanischen
Hintergrund genauso wie die Opfer er war
aber gleichzeitig wie auch die Opfer
amerikanischer Staatsbürger völlig Logan
legal im Land der ist doch zur Schule
gegangen ist dort aufgewachsen ist halt
in einer zerrütteten Familie
aufgewachsen mit Drogenproblemen in der
Familie ganz offenbar auch heftigen
Auseinandersetzungen er hat
Schwierigkeiten gehabt in der Schule er
ist gemobbt worden das entschuldigt ja
nicht seine Tat aber es zeigt dass diese
Gründe eine Rolle spielen wenn einer zum
Täter wird nur das zeigt eben auch dass
so ein kann man nicht einfach ausfindig
machen und präventiv wegsperren wie sich
mancher hier im rechtskonservativen
politischen Spektrum das so denkt Ausbau
der Sozialarbeit der psychologischen
Betreuung an Schulen sicherlich alles
wichtige Punkte aber am Ende kommt es
immer auch darauf an ob Waffen zur
Verfügung stehen und die USA sind glaube
ich das einzige Land der Erde dass es so
einfach macht ich habe es den Beitrag
gesagt
dass Menschen ihrer Zukunft ja ihres
Lebens beraubt werden das geht in
anderen Ländern anders da wo die
Waffengesetze strikter sind oder wo sie
in den letzten Jahren verschärft worden
sind wie beispielsweise in Australien
und den Neuseeland dann vertiefen wir
genau das auch an dieser Stelle Thomas
Gonser gonsor hat einen Beitrag darüber
gemacht wie das Verhältnis der
Amerikaner zu ihren Waffen ist
am großen Kaliber Kates kleine Hände
Texas selbst einige Kinder lernen in den
USA den Umgang mit Gewehren und Pistolen
kate ist 6 ihr AR-15 scheinbar ein
Spielzeug aber es ist tödlich peng peng
in pink
das macht Spaß und ich mag es meine
Waffe zu benutzen
Amerika waffenland in den USA sind laut
Studien etwa 300 Millionen Waffen im
Umlauf beinahe eine pro Einwohner und
eine Umfrage vergangenes Jahr ergab 47%
der Menschen leben in einem Haushalt mit
mindestens einer Schusswaffe die Waffe
sie gehört zum Gründungsmythos der USA
Freiheit gleich Freiheit der
Selbstverteidigung bereits in der
Verfassung ist 1791 das Recht verbrieft
Waffen zu besitzen und zu tragen
verteidigt wird das besonders von der
politisch einflussreichen NRW national
rifle Association auch wenn es immer
wieder Schulmassaker gibt wie in New
Town 2012 ebenfalls an einer Grundschule
26 Menschen sterben
und auch wenn die Waffengewalt in den
USA überhaupt zunimmt auch jüngst
Journalisten haben berechnet das
vergangenes Jahr mehr als
20.300 Menschen erschossen wurden rund
850 mehr als 2020 trotz der Gefahr sind
Waffen in den meisten US-Bundesstaaten
frei erhältlich etwa nach einem Check
auf Vorstrafen auch in Texas wo
vergangenes Jahr noch ein
Sicherheitskurs verpflichtend war im
September dann wurden die Waffengesetze
dort gelockert ab 18 darf nun jeder
Waffen erwerben auch der Schütze nun er
hatte zwei Halbautomatik Gewehre dabei
Typ AR15 das gibt es auch als Spielzeug
und wie bei Kate als Waffe in pink die
AR-15 aus dieser Waffe kamen die
tödlichen Kugeln bei Amokläufen in
Orlando parkland und vielen weiteren
Orten in den USA
die enorray bewirbt das Produkt in
netzvideos
erlernen und Bedienung easy das Töten
ganz einfach eben wie ein Kinderspiel
ja und zur Wahrheit gehört eben auch
dazu dass das AR-15 schreckliche Wunden
schreckliche Verletzungen und eben den
Tod auf grauenvolle Art und Weise mit
sich bringt Elmar eine Userin Namens
oder ein User namens Kuh fragt über
Youtube liegt die Änderung der
Waffengesetze in der Hand der Politik
oder in der Hand der Bevölkerung bzw der
Nutzer und ich ergänze oder in der Hand
der nr.a und wo genau fängt es an und wo
genau hört es auf
ja ein weites Feld würde Theodor Fontane
sagen aber es ist tatsächlich so dass
alle eine Rolle spielen dabei die
Politik die offenbar nicht die Kraft
findet der in AE die Stirn zu bieten die
nae die mit massiven Wahlkampfspenden
eben auch bestimmte politische Lager
unterstützt aber auch die Bevölkerung
die dazu beiträgt weil auch das sehen
wir in den Umfragewerten doch immer mehr
Amerikaner derzeit wieder er sagen wir
wollen Waffen besitzen dürfen das
bedeutet nicht notwendigerweise dass sie
auch gegen eine Einschränkung aller
Waffengesetze sind aber es gibt Umfragen
die eindeutig belegen dass sie
Zustimmung zu einer Verschärfung der
Waffengesetze in den letzten zwei drei
Jahren auch wieder gesunken ist und das
hängt wahrscheinlich damit zusammen was
ich vorhin schon mal gesagt habe diese
turbulenten politischen und sozialen
Umstände hier in den USA in den
vergangenen Jahren viele Menschen haben
Angst sie haben Angst dass nicht sie
Opfer von gewaltkriminellen werden
sondern möglicherweise auch in polit
Auseinandersetzungen wie wir sehen im
Jahr 2020 ja auch auf den Straßen erlebt
haben das ist da eben eine Notwendigkeit
gibt sich schützen zu müssen deshalb
sind die Waffenkäufe in die Luft
geschnellt also am Ende müssten alle
bereit sein und die große Frage ist wenn
man sich das ansieht wie kann es
eigentlich sein dass wenn man die
Geschichten dieser Menschen sieht jetzt
aus diesem kleinen Ort Juval der
Annabelle Rodriguez beispielsweise zehn
Jahre alt oder habe ihr Lopez den wir
vorhin schon einmal kurz gesehen haben
ebenfalls zehn Jahre alt die gestern
morgen einen tollen Tag zunächst hatten
denn sie hatten ihr ich sag mal
Abschlusszeugnis so nennt sich das
bekommen sie freuten sich darauf zur
Mittelschule zu gehen also in die nächst
höhere Schule nach der Grundschule zu
kommen hier nach den Sommerferien deren
Leben ist zerstört worden ihre
Hoffnungen ihre Zukunft und auch viele
Hoffnungen ihrer Eltern ihrer Verwandten
ihrer Freunde und ich glaube immer die
die unmittelbar betroffen sind
die werden sofort einsehen dass die
größte Seuche in diesem Land tatsächlich
die weite Verbreitung dieser Waffen ist
während alle die denken sie wären nicht
unmittelbar betroffen vielleicht auch
weil es ihnen wirtschaftlich besser geht
in diesem Land weil sie in sicheren
Wohngegenden leben weil sie sich Häuser
leisten können weil sie vielleicht auch
einfach der Gefahr aus dem Weg gehen
können als andere die machen sich
offenbar nicht genügend Gedanken darüber
und halten andere Themen für viel
wichtiger auch bei den kommenden Wahlen
jetzt im November und dann blicken wir
genau auf einen Politiker in dem sich
quasi dieses ganze dieser ganze Komplex
in einer Person manifestiert das ist
Greg Abbott Greg Abbott ist der
Gouverneur des Bundesstaates Texas und
er hat sich heute natürlich nach dieser
Tat sehr betroffen geäußert
wenn Eltern ihre Kinder in die Schule
bringen rechnen sie fest damit sie am
Ende des Schultags wieder abzuholen
nun trauern diese Familien und Texas
trauert mit Ihnen
dazu muss man aber wissen dass Greg
Abbott als enger Partner der nr.a gilt
dass er selbst im September 2021 die
Gesetze gelockert hat wonach jeder in
der Öffentlichkeit eine Waffe tragen
darf der mindestens 21 Jahre alt ist und
keiner ausdrücklichen Beschränkung zum
Tragen von Waffen unterliegt und es
lohnt sich auch noch mal einen Blick auf
Twitter zu werfen und zwar auf einen
Tweet von Greg Abbott den er vor sieben
Jahren
abgesetzt hat und da sagt er ich bin ja
schockiert Texas ist nur die Nummer zwei
wenn es um Waffenkäufe geht hinter
Kalifornien lasst uns dieses Rennen
gewinnen Texaner also mehr Waffen war
damals die Position von Greg Abbott
jetzt ist es so Elmar am Freitag ist die
Jahresversammlung der nr.a
passenderweise in Houston in Texas was
ist dazu erwarten wird gregabbit für
schärfere Waffengesetze plädieren oder
wird die Taktik möglicherweise sein zu
sagen wir brauchen mehr Waffen damit zum
Beispiel auch das ist ja eine Position
Lehrer zum Beispiel bewaffnet sind um
sich in solchen Fällen verteidigen zu
können
genau das wird passieren ich weiß nicht
ob Greg abiter selber sagen wird jetzt
bei dieser Versammlung wenn er dabei ist
aber wir hören das immer und immer
wieder nach diesen Schießereien dass
gerade im republikanischen Lager
gefordert wird man müsste noch mehr
Waffen verteilen und zwar eben in der
Tat an die Lehrer die sollen sowas in
ihrer Schreibtischschublade haben und um
dann eben die Kinder zu schützen in
solch einer Situation man fordert auch
immer mehr Polizei an der Schule es gibt
hier in vielen Landkreisen in den USA
schon Polizisten an den Schulen auch
hier in Washington und gerade wurde
ihren Washington drüber diskutiert ob
man das wieder abschafft weil es sendet
natürlich das Signal dass Kinder sich
jeden Tag mit dem Gedanken
auseinandersetzen müssen dass sie
vielleicht in ihrer Schule erschossen
werden könnten das gibt es in keinem
Land der Erde eigentlich nur in den USA
aber es gibt andere Länder die es ich
sprachs vorhin schon mal an offenbar
besser machen Australien Neuseeland
haben ihre Waffen Gesetze in den letzten
Jahren dramatisch verschärft sie sind
hingegangen und haben Waffen
zurückgekauft Details mit Steuergeldern
mit regierungsgeldern haben sie den
Menschen Waffen abgekauft illegale
Waffen die im Land unterwegs waren da
sind 10.000 vielleicht Hunderttausende
von Waffen zurückgekauft worden die
wurden dann vernichtet und in der
Statistik in Australien kann man das
auch jetzt schon eindeutig belegen in
Neuseeland ist das noch nicht so schnell
nachweisbar aber kann man belegen dass
eben die Gewaltverbrechen mit Waffen
deutlich gesunken sind also es gäbe im
Grunde genommen Muster aber
ehrlicherweise in den USA gibt es in der
Bevölkerung nicht genügend die bereit
sind das durchzusetzen und
möglicherweise bekommen Sie hier aus
Washington auch Hilfe dabei denn der
Oberste Gerichtshof soll in den nächsten
Wochen in einem Fall eine Entscheidung
fällen wo es auch um das Recht Waffe zu
tragen geht
schauen wir genauer auf Australien wir
können uns die Situation da genauer
angucken denn auch da war das was du
gerade angesprochen hast ein Amoklauf
der Auslöser bis in den 90er Jahre waren
die Waffengesetze und Zustände in
Australien mit denen der USA
vergleichbar dann kam der Amoklauf von
1996 in Port after Tasmanien tötet ein
Mann 34 Menschen und verletzt 23 weitere
in den Wochen danach fordern viele
Austern viele Australier schärfere
Regeln und die kommen dann auch Gesetze
wurden verschärft Waffen eingesammelt
wie Elmas gerade angesprochen hat und
seitdem gab es keinen einzigen Amoklauf
mehr in Australien außerdem ist die Zahl
der todeswelle durch Schusswaffen
halbiert worden und nun ist eben die
Frage wie ist das gelungen Elmar hat es
gerade angesprochen und wir haben
darüber gesprochen mit Rebecca Peters
die frühere Präsidentin des
international Action network on small
arms das ist eine australische
nichtregierungs Organisation gegen
Kleinwaffen
wir hatten gerade eine neue Wahl mit
einem brandneuen Premierminister er war
überzeugt dass er genug Zeit für
Veränderungen hatte ohne den Druck von
anstehenden Wahlen also hat er alle
Bundesstaaten zusammengerufen und gesagt
das ist der Zeitpunkt wo wir was
verändern können
die Bundesstaaten waren einverstanden
und haben den Forderungen unser Kampagne
zugestimmt
eine wichtige Änderung war das Verbot
von halbautomatischen Waffen und der
Rückkauf
es waren zu dieser Zeit viele solcher
Waffen im Umlauf und deshalb gab es ein
Programm diese zurückzugeben nachdem sie
illegal geworden sind
die Regierung hatte ihnen Geld für diese
Waffen gegeben
25 Jahre nach dem Verbot von
halbautomatischen Waffen und diesem
Rückkauf sehen wir dass diese Maßnahmen
gewirkt haben
wir hatten kaum noch Amokläufe nur
kleinere Vorfälle und das auch nur in
den letzten Jahren
davor hatten wir 25 Jahre lang keinen
einzigen Amoklauf
ein wichtig der Punkt ist auch dass die
Menschen in Australien keine Angst haben
in Amerika muss man immer Angst haben
dass jemand eine Waffe hat was passieren
könnte und wir in Australien denken
darüber gar nicht nach
interessant Elmar denn das Wort Angst
hast du vorhin auch schon verwendet
welche Rolle spielt der Faktor Angst in
dieser Diskussion in Amerika
ja ich glaube ein großer je mehr ist
eben solche Massaker gibt und ich nannte
ja vorhin mal die Zahl 3500 in den
letzten zehn Jahren also Schießereien
bei denen mindestens vier Menschen ums
Leben gekommen sind sorgt das natürlich
dafür dass Menschen sich selber
bewaffnen weil sie denken sie müssten
sich schützen
das schaukelt sich dann natürlich weiter
aus es kommt glaube ich auch noch ein
Stück weit Öl ins Feuer durch die
politische Polarisierung im Land und das
haben wir ja gerade vor zehn Tagen
gesehen als in Buffalo im Bundesstaat
New York ein Schütze Kunden in einem
Supermarkt ermordet hat aus
rassistischen Motiven und diese
rassistischen Motive fielen nicht vom
Himmel herunter sondern er war unterwegs
mit einer Theorie der sogenannten
Bevölkerungsaustausch Theorie die hier
in den USA offen von Politikern der
republikanischen Partei offen von
talkmastern im amerikanischen Fernsehen
bei Fox News und anderen Sendern
verbreitet wird die übrigens auch in
Europa von Politikern der ungarischen
englischpartei von Viktor Orban
verbreitet wird auch auf von
afd-abgeordneten in Deutschland und
diese Theorie diese Behauptung dass es
hier darum gehe die weiße Bevölkerung zu
ersetzen durch andere die befeuert das
Ganze eben auch und sorgt dafür dass es
auch aus diesen Gründen solche Master
gibt solche Amokläufe und Master und das
sorgt dann wieder für eine Steigerung
der Angst also es ist im Grunde genommen
ein tödlicher Kreislauf ein Teufelskreis
der hier stattfindet und die große Frage
ist wie man das Brechen kann
Alexander Hanel hat noch eine Frage auch
zum Thema Angst muss man sich als
Europäer besonders fürchten wenn man in
den USA auf Reise geht dass man mit
einer Schusswaffe bedroht oder verletzt
wird
also die gute Nachricht ist wenn wir
vergleichen mit den 90er Jahren dann ist
beispielsweise hier in Washington die
Kriminalitätsrate nicht höher deutlich
höher als das was wir damals hatten sie
war über viele Jahre sogar niedriger
mittlerweile ist sie wieder gestiegen in
den letzten zwei Jahren aus den vorhin
schon mal genannten Gründen aber das
bedeutet im Umkehrschluss und ich habe
hier auch in den 90er Jahren in
Washington gelebt damals galt das hier
als die mord-hauptstadt der USA hatte
also die höchste Mordrate dass man sich
trotzdem sicher bewegen kann wenn man
eben darauf achtet was man tut also als
normaler Reisender als Tourist im Land
ist das Risiko glaube ich extrem gering
denn ein Großteil dieser Gewalt findet
in Gegenden statt in denen nicht
unbedingt Touristen unterwegs sind oder
errichtet sich meistens eben innerhalb
der jeweiligen Gemeinschaften in den
Städten gegen Amerikaner gegen Mitbürger
es schließt nicht aus dass am Ende auch
Touristen davon betroffen sein könnten
wenn sie ich sag mal hier in Washington
etwas wo in eine Schießerei
hineingeraten würde würden aber ich
denke mit der entsprechenden Vorsicht
kann man weiterhin hier in den USA sehr
sehr sicher unterwegs sein
mit den Worten von André Lötscher der
schreibt über Youtube Elmar macht einen
super Job möchte ich mich bei dir
herzlich bedanken immer dass du zu
diesem tragischen Vorfall mit uns
gesprochen hast und uns so mitgenommen
hast in die Geschichte und auch in die
amerikanische Seele was die Kultur des
Waffen Tragens und der Waffengesetze
angeht vielen Dank Elmar theversen nach
Washington
und damit auch an Sie liebe Userinnen
und User ein herzliches Dankeschön für
mitkommen fürs mit kommentieren und mit
Fragen und ich sage Tschüss im Namen des
Teams bis zum nächsten Mal